[Musique]
et on commence ses informations Gabriel
par une nouvelle évacuation au château
de Versailles oui c'est la 4e fois que
ça arrive après les évacuations de
samedi dernier mardi et hier le château
de versaill a dû à nouveau fermer ses
portes un peu avant 14h aujourd'hui pour
une nouvelle alerte à la bombe après des
vérifications le site a pu réouvrir vers
16h et on espère pour eux que la
situation va se calmer à partir de
demain ce sont les Journ jnée nationale
de la réparation 3 jours pour
sensibiliser aux enjeux de la réparation
vous l'avez dit Mathilde les 20 21 et 22
octobre prochain c'est la première
édition des Journées Nationales dédié à
cette problématique dans les Yvelines
des ateliers sont organisés dans des
enseignes au chénéau cancours sur 50 ans
en Eveline SOS accessoir à morpa
distiler conseil et diagnostic même
programme dans une enseigne
d'électroénager à coignère et à plaisir
un atelier d'entretien et de réparation
et proposé é par l'association
cyclospien des clés sous-bois vous allez
nous parler à présent d'un événement qui
a rassemblé des entreprises ivelinoises
autour du sport le trophée des
entreprises de 50 ans en yeline s'est
tenu aujourd'hui au Golf National à Guy
encour big orange ou encore Coca-Cola ce
rendez-vous annuel a réuni plus de 70
sociétés du territoire qui ont pu
s'essayer au célèbre parcours de
l'albatrose l'objectif créer un
écosystème d'entrepreneurs pour fédérer
autour du sport on écoute les réactions
au micro de Julien Leroi c'est un vrai
esprit de compétition il y a vraiment
des gagnants il y a des perdants on
passe en général sur les perdant parce
que c'est un golf pour le coup agréable
et donc on n'est pas là pour stigmatiser
son comp perdu d'ailleurs moi-même j'ai
joué et je ne pense être très très loin
d'avoir gagné mais l'idée c'est que
chacun apporte son présent son cadeau
soit partenaire de l'événement et puisse
en fonction de ce qu'il produit de ce
qui lui fait plaisir l'offrir aux autrre
le résseutage effectivement est
important et puis ça nous permet de
aussi de de montrer notre attachement
au territoire et à 5 an ivelin on
poursuit avec une information sur le
terroir ivelinois cet après-midi avait
lieu le concours du pâté de Houdan oui
les gourmands ont pu se régaler cet
après-midi puisque se tenait le concours
annuel du pâté de Houdan organisé par la
confrériie gastronomique de la poule et
du pâté de Houdan un concours ouvert à
tous avec trois catégories les
professionnels les apprentis élèves et
stagiaires de formation professionnelle
et des particuliers alors c'est éétait
la 5e édition le gourmand chez tv78
c'est Grégory canalé son reportage sera
à retrouver la semaine prochaine dans
cette édition oui c'est un pâté à base
de volail je vous le conseille il est il
est très bon Gabriel testé un mot de
sport à présent et de football plus
particulièrement oui le tirage au sort
du 6e tour de la Coupe de France a eu
lieu hier soir on connaît désormais les
adversaires de nos trois clubs yvelinois
encore présent dans la compétition le
châau club de N3 se déplacera sur le
terrain de Tor une équipe de Régionale 1
ouille en R1 se rendra sur le terrain
des couant qui joue en D1 enfin le FC
Versailles demi-finaliste il il y a deux
saisons jouera à domicile contre Fleury
qui évolue en National 2 le 6e tour se
jouera les 28 et les 29 octobre prochain
et on termine avec un petit point Bison
Futé oui vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
ce vendredi c'est le début des vacances
de la toussin alors certains d'entre
vous vont très certainement prendre la
route pas grand-chose à signaler si ce
n'est un trafic de contexte habituel
desbouch d'un vendredi soir bisonfuté
place la région île-de-fance en orange
et donne comme conseil de quitter ou
traverser la région avant 14h le reste
du weekend tous les voyants sont ouverts
et bien merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier
pour toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous le communiquer sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 78 news